un bon jour tous les oiseaux
venez vite nous sommes en train
d'écouter tous les chants des oiseaux
vous les entendez et si on jouait les
reconnaître d'accord les oiseaux s'il
vous plaît voulait chanter les uns après
les autres
pourquoi on voudrait faire un jeu
d'accord merci voilà le premier
j'entendais encore un petit peu pour lui
qu'est ce que ce fait placé chercher où
c'est chez vous encore un petit peu
s'il te plaît à cochons ou te dire à
cochons c'est pas un oiseau ni don alors
que ce sellers c'est pas top c'est pas
une poule je le dis hein c'est un
perroquet c'est entendu un perroquet tu
le savais pas et vous et pourquoi tu l'a
pas dit si le savez pourrait dire pas
dit s'il le savait allez on en écoute un
autre le coq tu es sûr vous aviez trouvé
chez vous
mais oui c'était le coq encore un autre
s'il te plait un autre casino
il est là où louis écouter chanter
chante encore un petit peu
voilà c'est pas le mot no non lumière là
c'est en herbe
c'est pierre qui a trouvé c'était un air
vous aviez trouvé non regarde c'est
celui qui est là où kim est donc il a
chanté vas-y on t'écoute
c'est quand il y en a encore un peu non
regardez le reconnaître de tête
qu'est ce que tu as dit bruno c'est un
rossignol tu crois tu es rossignol
tournant oui eh bien oui c'était un
rossignol
allez c'est lui qui l'a par nathan qui a
chanté alors que charles pour voilà
c'est ça c'est ça mais encore dit que
pour des amis chez eux à vienne en
autriche en même temps d'ailleurs c'est
le rossignol qui chante derrière c'est
le coup de cour c'est bruno qui a trouvé
malgré tu l'avais dit fabrice et bien
bravo champion
tu avais encore une hausse à brice
encore une autre demande lui à celui
qu'elle a pas de chanter chante chante
pour nous de là haut vas-y voilà
[Musique]
cool line poule c'est un oiseau laurence
sylvain cvan wet là bas qu'est ce que
c'est encore un petit peu
[Musique]
non c'est une chouette
allez encore un pic voyez là vous allez
trouver ça fabrice et s'il a le soleil
dans les yeux
alors c'est un canard voilà c'est un
canard à canards sauvages d'ailleurs a
dû laver sur le bout de la langue du
volet le dire et ça venait pas tout à
fait quand même trouvé alors bon encore
une autre allée à les oiseaux là
n'importe lequel
voilà je reconnais celui là aussi non
ennemis chez vous l'avez déjà entendu je
suis cherché cherché mais je vous dis
c'est le petit oiseau des îles as tu
vois que tu avais déjà un évolué ces
pays où il n ya le petit oiseau désiré
dallo au oui il a fait sonner vient
michel le chanteur ne doit pas être loin
vous n'avez pas vu personne n'a vu et
chez nos amis non une chercher échelle
au michel allons chercher dans l'île aux
enfants
regardez le garder l'oeil d'or là bas
michel ah oui je me repose et oui tu
veux être gentille il va nous chanter la
chanson du petit oiseau des îles sommes
évoquées oui bien sûr aller
bah
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs si tu le vois volé
dans la grand'rue suit le connaîtra le
bas rhin si tu veux boire on est dans la
grande île
suit le hic tu connaîtras le bonheur
[Musique]
nenê
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui est
entré dans mon corps il se faisait dans
la vie tranquille et marie je m'appelle
balade il s'est posé dans la vie
tranquille et marie-jo matin la valeur
m
me
depuis ce jour là je vis
un peu comme au paradis
et si tu veux boire l'amour rien on chez
moi partout
non non non non non
[Musique]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui
mangent au creux de ma main
c'est un territoire fragile qui
chaussent même chez le matin c'est
tintin
toi au fragile quichotte sous la douche
le matin
[Musique]
m
depuis ce jour là je dis un peu comme
mon paradis
et si tu veux voir l'amour
d'ailleurs chez moi
[Musique]
non non non non
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs si tu le vois pas
donner dans la grande île suis levé qui
connaîtra le venin si tu ne bois pas de
la grand ville suit l'équipe connaîtra
le bonheur
si tu le bois volet dallas gorille 6e et
reconnaîtra de bonheur si tu doivent
aller de l'avant ville suit le et que tu
colles et ras le bol
[Musique]